i don't know why they make me up i  didn't say nothing yeah i love to travel  through the legs  i see the five steps i like you i like  it  if it's six falls  am i going out of the game that's good  fundamental basketball come down with it  big feather did you ever miss a  mid-range shot three-point champ that's  a totally different day it's a different  day  all my mates came yesterday  yes i can still shoot  coach i'm gonna have to talk to pat man  i don't like my minutes bro  yes so  cats in the game i like our chances are  they listening to me  are they listening to me  see this is this is the type of things  that happen that make people think the  nba script  i swear  you can't make it up anymore fade away  in cleveland for all the brands  that was inside tracks phenomenal